welcome back to retro rewind I was going
to say welcome to retro rewind because
this is kind of the start of a new thing
but I've already done this segment
before if you guys saw my Toonami retro
rewind I enjoyed it so much and it was
one of my favorite videos to ever work
on and hope you guys watched my channel
update video that I posted last week
because that kind of explains what's
going on here so you guys can really
know what's happening but in case you
missed that video I'm going to be doing
these retro rewinds every other week
along with hilarious ''tis every single
Sunday - hilarious ''tis a month - retro
rewinds a month and it's basically just
my excuse to talk about something from
my past that infected infected and it's
basically just my excuse to talk about
something from my past that had a good
impact on me or maybe a terrible impact
anything really it's just a whatever
video two times a month and this week
we're going to be talking about tremors
tremors is something that is kind of
personal to me in a strange way the
movie is tons of fun I really loved the
first tremors movie I loved the
simplicity of it I loved that it's just
such a simple movie I think sometimes
movies like this try to overthink
themselves way too much and I think a
lot of first-time screenwriters also
think that they have to bust onto the
scene with this insane screenplay that's
just like mind-boggling like 2001 a
Space Odyssey or Inception or something
that just blows everyone away but you
can actually make a really good film on
an extremely simple idea and with
tremors we have some worms under the
ground they don't like people and you
know everyone's gonna die and Kevin
Bacon it's such a simple idea it's such
a basic idea but it works because the
film itself is extremely fun and
relentlessly paced it's also a very
funny movie in a way it's a horror
comedy and usually those two genres
they're rarely ever mixed either your
film is a horror film that's so bad it's
hilarious or they were trying to make it
scary and it just didn't work out so
you're sitting there laughing or it
could be like Evil Dead 2 a film that
really understands those two genres
being meshed together and with tremors
they got it
I love this movie it is so much fun why
is it special to me besides the fact
that when I was a kid I loved all the
tremors movies I mean literally all of
them
and the TV show a lot of people actually
don't remember there is a tremors TV
show short-lived but not a terrible show
well my experience with tremors was
essentially this my friends and I when
we were very young like elementary
school-aged had this game we played at
playgrounds and we called it tremors now
one person was the tremor and everyone
else were the humans and the only safe
place would be on high ground so if you
could get on top of like a brick
structure or a jungle gym
you'd be safe but if the tremor touches
you you're dead and whoever is the last
human standing essentially wins and my
friends and I played that all the time
the funny part of the story is is I
actually didn't know what it was for
because I hadn't seen tremors yet
because we were like I don't know six or
seven years old and I hadn't yet seen
tremors until I was probably about ten
and so I was like what is this this game
is cool I like it and then one day I
watched tremors and I was just like ah
everything makes sense now so the first
film has always had a special place to
me in my heart and I just re-watched it
last night and I think it's a ton of fun
still as an adult it really works as a
horror comedy a really fun monster movie
there's no explanation given for why
these things they come to call graboids
are underneath the ground they even
specifically say who cares where they
come from we just have to figure out how
to survive and that's what I love about
this screenplay the screenplay wasn't
like you know we had to explain
everything there's a whole bunch of
exposition it was just oh crap there's
some man eating worms burrowing under
the ground and how do we get away from
them and I'm not gonna sit here and talk
like tremors is a classic or anything
even though it is I'm I know there isn't
much to tremors but should there be I
mean it's a movie about killer worms
with Kevin Bacon Fred Ward and Michael
Gross fresh off of Family Ties shooting
up everything and it's funny because
Michael Gross kind of became the star of
the series he was in every single film
after that even the most recent tremors
five which was not good as well as the
TV show he just kept coming back for
more and it became his own little
monster movie star in his own right
which is funny because when you watch a
show like Family Ties you don't expect
this guy to become like the badass of a
monster movie franchise but he did as
for this
equals three and four and especially
five there okay I guess five is like uh
no but two is not the greatest but I
still have a lot of fun with it
two is actually more nostalgic for me
than the first one is two was the first
one where they could walk around on land
and there's that amazing shot with that
giant gun that just blows up the one
tremors head
and it's funny because when I was doing
some research for this movie I came
across the trivia on IMDB where SS
Wilson the creator of this whole tremors
thing talked about how when he was in
the military or whatever he was sitting
on a rock and he thought wouldn't be
strange if something was keeping me on
this rock and I couldn't get off this
rock because I would die if I did he's
just so funny than a guy sitting
somewhere on a rock came up with an idea
made a successful franchise out of it
and some elementary schoolers in the 90s
came up with a playground idea for a
game and it's just that's how shit works
it's crazy
it's nuts it's total guilty pleasure fun
and that's one of the biggest reasons I
wanted to restart this retro rewind
segment because I wanted to talk about
films that weren't just hilarious ities
from my childhood films that maybe
aren't the greatest but they're
certainly not bad they're just awesome
and fun and tremors is definitely one of
those movies if you've never seen it
give it a watch it is a damn good time
and Kevin Bacon's in it and that's
always a plus
guys I hope you enjoyed this installment
of retro rewind my upcoming hilarious
'ti next Sunday is going to be for
Supergirl and in that video I will tell
you what my next retro rewind will be
and that's how I'm going to do it it'll
be my fun little Sunday thing for you
guys going back and forth between those
two segments and it's a good way to have
more variety on my channel and talk
about more than just everything you
always hear me talking about and kind of
change up the pace a little bit thank
you guys so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes
you